with people staying home and not
traveling during the pandemic demand for
oil has plummeted a key benchmark
determining crude oil prices fell below
zero for the first time ever yesterday
it has since rebounded but low oil
prices can be disastrous for regions
that rely on drilling and fracking for
jobs and tax revenue in our coronavirus
series financial fallout Janet shamlian
traveled to West Texas to see how the
collapse is affecting people there good
morning while the economy is reeling
from coronavirus this part of West Texas
the heart of the energy industry in
America is dealing with a double blow
now long ago Midland was a boomtown now
preparing for a bust
Chris Toki is trying to convince himself
as much as he's trying to comfort his
four young daughters he's a fourth
generation Midland oilfield worker and
like so many Americans he was laid off
last week unlike others coronavirus
isn't the main culprit we got hit with a
double whammy whenever it come to this
between the Saudi and Russia price war
that started around about the same time
the coronavirus hit kind of
unprecedented times for us out here out
here is the Permian Basin which Midland
is part of the region produces roughly
1/3 of US oil it had been booming new
construction everywhere then the price
war and coronavirus sent prices
spiraling Monday to the lowest level in
history the city of about 140,000 now
tops the list of those that would be
hardest hit by a recession according to
the public policy group the Brookings
Institution it's like someone hit the
switch and all of a sudden layoffs
already start all of a sudden the city
starts to slow down and you can
literally feel it Mayor Patrick Payton
says once coronavirus hit it grounded
planes and kept drivers off the roads
dealing a devastating blow to demand for
oil and bringing Midland
it's nice now one of the city's best
restaurants is a food pantry free lunch
for first responders and anyone who
can't afford to buy groceries the
outlook isn't good
the mayor says because so many jobs here
are oil related the region will recover
behind the rest of the country it's
probably at least a two-year lift for us
to get this economy moving again this
boom we were in was about a five-year
run it took us a week to lose it for the
dokey family two years is an eternity
their savings won't last that long how
are you gonna make your mortgage with a
lot of a lot of prayers and just trying
to stay on top of things and my main
goal is to feed my family
but shortly thereafter that is to
continue to provide them shelter for
them to lay their heads down at night
rig workers engineers and the thousands
of others in the industry previously had
little trouble finding other work in
downturns but in the world of
coronavirus no one is hiring that was
Janet shamlian reporting on some real
tough times in the oil industry